ROMAN NURIK: There are a lot
of ways to design something.
That blank canvas you get at
the start of many projects,
I think it's something that
designers and developers love
about what they do.
And for every 100 complicated
solutions to a design problem,
there's only a
handful of simple ones
that I think will work
and be successful.
I think it's why simplicity
in design is so revered.
I'm Roman, a designer in
the Firebase team at Google,
New York.
And I love this little
app called Circuit.
And I want to talk about some
of the design details that
make it so beautifully simple.
So Circuit is an app that solves
the traveling salesman problem.
You give it a couple
of destinations
and it figures out the optimal
order to visit those places.
I'll add a couple
of my favorite spots
here in New York
as a quick example.
Once I'm done, I can
hit this nice big button
to calculate the
route, and proceed
to navigate on Google Maps.
And that's it, simple.
I did all that in
under a minute.
So let's talk about some
of the design choices
here that I think
are really great.
First is contrast.
At any given point, these
big splashes of blue
clearly draw my attention
to what I should do next.
Now the app also uses verbs
like improve, navigator,
and calculate.
And this creates affordances.
You don't always need
special visual treatments
to make something
look clickable.
Now while we're on the
subject of UI text,
one minor suggestion is
instead of using title case,
to use sentence case in labels
like Remaining route or Total
estimated savings here.
This will make the app feel
a little bit friendlier.
Speaking of which, this
expand and collapse transition
here is dead simple, but
done incredibly well.
So as the one-line
summary moves up and down,
the other elements, they
slide and they fade with it.
And this creates this
consistent spatial relationship
between expanded and
collapsed states.
It almost establishes
this one-line summary
as a synecdoche, a symbol
for the expanded state.
I think it's something
that's very powerful
for these progressive
disclosure UIs,
and can make them
much more successful.
So notice how in
the map in the list,
there's a bunch of shared
visual elements-- the step
circles, the flag, and then
the path to the next step
is a darker blue, compared
to all the other paths
that are a lighter blue.
Using a coherent visual
language like this,
is a great way to
connect related elements
throughout your
app, without needing
to use a legend or
any other visual aids.
It's a great way to encourage
your users to really
quickly build a mental model
for how your app works.
One idea here is to go a step
further and differentiate
previous paths
from upcoming ones.
In general, I think it's always
a great idea to consider users
past, present, and future.
Finally, let's talk about
something at play here
that's invisible.
If I click on Edit, you'll
see that this app is following
the 8dp grid and keylines
from Material Design
to create harmony across the UI.
If I turn on a couple
of nice overlays,
you'll see what
I'm talking about.
First, I'll use the
grid and keylines
overlay from this app
called Designer Tools.
And then I'll turn on Show
Layout Bounds from Android's
Developer Options.
Aligning elements through
these natural visual guides
is a great way to create
order and balance in your UI.
The human brain is really
good at pattern recognition,
and it's even better at spotting
things that break that pattern.
So remember to be
deliberate whenever things
aren't aligned in your app.
So those are some of my favorite
visual tidbits in Circuit.
It uses contrast to clearly
tell me what I should do next.
It employs a clear
visual language
to create cohesion
throughout the app.
It uses motion to subtly express
the relationship between what's
visible and what's hidden.
And it creates harmony in the
UI by using Material Design's
8dp grid and keylines.
These little details,
and many more,
make this app feel very
simple and easy to use.
And that's something
that I think
that all designers and
developers should aspire to.
If you have an app you
want us to take a look at,
click here to submit it.
And make sure to
subscribe to our channel
for more awesome design videos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]